A brilliant soldier,...
...a revolutionary statesman,...
...a man who joined his fate with the destiny of his nation.
In 1915, at Gallipoli,...
...he handed the British one of the most devastating defeats in their history.
In 1918, he emerged from World War I as the only undefeated Ottoman commander.
Four years later, he led his people in their struggle against the invading Greek forces...
...and won back their independence.
In 1923, on the ruins of the defunct Ottoman Empire,...
...he founded and became the first president of the Republic of Turkey.
Six months later, he became the first leader to attack and defeat Islamic theocracy.
With the seeds of democracy he planted,...
...the nation he cultivated, endured tribulations both from inside and outside for decades.
Stalin considered him a fascist.
Hitler and Mussolini said he was a communist.
Others called him a dictator.
His people called him Ataturk, Father Turk.